starting the unplugging process my wife
I found out that she's been VM and guys
old friends from high school so a little
backstory we've been together for 13
years now while we're together we she
would meet up with them meet a pal like
Mike I'm going out with a friend
tomorrow for lunch yeah yeah yeah with
Bob exactly I respect her but then on
the second hand it's like well how do I
unplug well you let that happen this is
number five on my red flag list she
keeps men from her past around what does
she say when you confront her oh she got
defensive at first she's like well you
know what are you doing my phone etc etc
you're going to get out of life what you
tolerate the thing that you got to do
Mike is you got to put your foot down to
set some boundaries look if we're going
to be married and you're going to be my
wife you don't talk to other guys you
don't go out with other guys that's the
reality of this relationship and if you
can't do that you can get [ __ ] and get
out but are you gonna do it though now
right like you have the balls to make
sure you put your foot down you you know
set that boundary because if you don't
she's going to keep walking all over you
so it's on you to stop that and if and
if she doesn't stop it and it keeps
going in a Direction you don't like walk
you don't have kids who cares put the
matrimony Assets in a pile and just get
rid of her